oh
hi what are you doing here
okay come in are you kidding me whatever
what do you want do you want to talk to
me whatever how do you feel good
what do you want to talk about
away with my mom today
okay how was that was perfect was good
oh good
i told him my side the story because she
having you you never telling what's
going to happen for real
well it's hard for me to sit down and
tell her that her son
asked for a separation after he brought
home keys with another woman's name on
it
i didn't want to tell her all the things
that are going on with us because that's
too invasive i came here to make my
relationship with your mom and my mom
they i never been doing anything in the
house they are not spending time with
you you don't they might okay and then
what does that say why you say listen
like that you talked to my mom about
what's going on in the house you told my
mom that i'm lazy and i don't do any
work and i don't clean up that's what
you told my mom okay because they asked
me
i didn't go to your mom's house to
bad-mouth you i went to your mom's house
to show you that i'm willing to work on
our relationship to make things better
sorry if you don't appreciate it
open the door no because you need to
change your attitude oh i need the gym i
do look at you i did you have to change
your attitude first
i feel like i've been fighting for our
relationship to work and it's turned
into each of us in
separate corners fighting against each
other
it feels like a twisted game of cat and
mouse
this is not what i've ever imagined like
i don't want to be chasing my husband
for attention and affection and
conversation
and you want to talk
come in if you want to come on in if you
want to yeah come in soon
we're staying in separate rooms at the
same hotel
i mean i don't fish
i don't know
i don't know i can't explain that i
don't have any words to describe that
it's ridiculous
[Music]
[Music]